-Right!
-That's the Hugo we know!
Go!
He's a great athlete.
Yeah.
The honest truth is,
I've thought about what it'd be like
if you never started metal boxing.
But if you did box,
I wanted you to have a clean-fighting jock
like Hugo to be your opponent.
Hugo versus Levius. If I were a fan,
that's what I'd want to see the most.
Yeah, you're right, Uncle.
Hugo's amazing.
The steam tubes are cracked.
The valves are also breaking.
And his Agartha water's nearly gone...
Hugo, you've fought well.
You've pleased the fans―
Not yet. It can't end yet...
If you keep this up, your career―
Old man!
Please!
Next, the sixth round! The final round!
I've got to continue what Jones started.
-What the...
-That stance?
Is he a kid, just learning to box?
Amazing...
Yeah, he's cut out the showiness,
but he's fighting to win.
Boss! That's all he can take!
The Cross Screw!
-Did he do it?!
-Hugo?